all right so let's start with a simple
idea I'll show you how to do it and then
we're gonna go outside and do some
different things so here's what we
started right trig ratio started like
this remember we've been drawing a whole
bunch of these right-angled triangles
yeah and then we would say look this
shot angle over here who knows what it
is let's call that theta right and then
you might get provided with for instance
you might get given these legs this is a
right angle triangle and you can check
those numbers out with Pythagoras if you
wanted okay
so we introduce sine cos and tan sine
cos theta and theta and we use that in
the morning right are you sick to death
rolls off the tongue [ __ ] I thought what
is um with we use this ability to
remember what these ratios were equal to
right so sine theta is equal to whatever
what purpose opposite over hypotenuse so
we can actually write down these numbers
right opposite on our body so in this
case in this triangle
it'd be 5 over 13 good cos theta is
going to be from the demonic and Jason
on like what is so that's this one down
here 12 over 13 and you last one tennis
hits someone else let's see yes a pair
opposite over adjacent opposite over
adjacent so the number we're gonna write
it is 512 okay so remember these all
ratios how we've been getting them we've
just been reading them off the
measurements that we've got that's all
okay but sometimes you get different
measurements for instance here I've got
all of these legs and I don't know the
angle but sometimes you know what the
angle is okay so here's an example let's
draw this up
yeah draw this one up
let's call this one okay so here is just
silly examples all right all right now
suppose what I'm interested in is what's
the hypotenuse in this triangle it's a
right angle triangle
usually when we want the hypotenuse we
would say this squared plus this squared
it was this square we would use
Pythagoras right except except the time
to reflect this is right I don't know
what this other like this of Pythagoras
is kind of not helpful enough here right
but we can use our trig ratios right
remember I'm trying to find out this
right so let me give it a name let's
call it X meters right we always we use
pretty rules moving like it's a number
but I don't know what it is now you've
got an angle over here these two sides
we've got hypotenuse adjacent opposite
which two sides of these ones good good
this one the long one is always the
hypotenuse right and this one's over the
other side right so which ratio tells
you opposite over hypotenuse look
carefully sine opposite up one music
here gets of sine right okay so here's
what I'm going to write down I'm going
to write sine off instead of feet up I
know what the angle is this time it's
sine 30 degrees okay by the way just as
a short note please don't just write say
30 I know it's very tempting you have to
write it all the time you're like god do
I have to really write the degrees sine
the extras you should because there's
more than one way to measure degrees
sorry I measure angles not just degrees
there are other units okay so sine 30
degrees
it's it's nestled under mode I can show
you how to change it later but you
should because it should be few degrees
okay now we said it was opposite or
hypotenuse right so what should I write
in here which sides are officer and
which ones are point yeah it's going to
be extra four right which ones on top
it's opposite opposite over hypotenuse
so I'm gonna write four over X is that
okay okay now remember X is what I'm
trying to find okay but here's what your
calculator comes in here's your
calculator this is about using trig
ratios with a calculator this sine 30
degrees did you ever watch this and we
looked at the fact that sine 30 degrees
is actually a number right and your
calculator can tell you what it is
so you find sine in the middle of your
calculator on one of those smaller
buttons you just hit site and then you
put in 30 so I think and it should give
you an answer what does it give you 0.5
or 1/2 so I've just evaluated sine 30 as
in I found its value okay using my
calculator okay are you stretching or I
ask you a question okay now what did I
want to do I wanted to find X right so
I'll rearrange this a little bit let's
see of x X so he'll go over this side
and then I'll divide by 0.5 so he'll
come over this side like this is a bit
awkward we're mixing fractions and
decimals but that's okay we just want to
answer at the end for this for this case
so again you can reach for your
calculator if you struggle to do this
and you can say well 4 divided by so
your point 5 and it'll give you an
answer what does it give you give you 8
now just for the sake of it right I'm
going to show you how to do it by not
using attacker because these are very
easy numbers it's 4 divided by 1/2 right
now when you divide by a fraction what
do you do do you remember how to divide
by a fraction I can turn the division
into multiplication provided
I'd turn this upside down so that's
going to become the truth right so
that's okay okay
so hmm okay what are we just established
we can find on the length of the
triangle if we evaluate trig ratios with
a calculator okay and that's the way
that I would do that I guess I should
say yeah it's okay